Es ist Zeit, auf den europäischen Fußball der Männer zu blicken. Und das heißt, heute in der Ligatour sprechen wir über La Liga, die Serie A, die Premier League und die Eredivisie mit Daniel Zander, Mario Rieker, Jogi Hebel, Nies Kern. Jetzt geht's los!
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
So und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schönen Gruß in meine Runde. Wir sparen uns jetzt den Lehrer-Call. Ich versuche, ihn wegzulassen. Schön, dass ihr alle da seid. Ihr müsst nicht reagieren. Wir gehen gleich rein in die Sendung. Wir wollen es so kompakt halten, wie möglich. Und ich würde sagen, Yogi, dass wir in der Premier League beginnen. Denn die Entlassung von Eric ten Hag bei Manchester United, finally. Ich hätte schon gedacht, dass wir letztes Jahr oder vorletztes Jahr das mal in der Ligatur besprechen. Jetzt ist es dann doch passiert. Was hat denn das fast zum Überlaufen gebracht?
Alles Weitere dann in eurer Folge Click&Rush, die wird natürlich in die Show Notes gepackt mit dem Kapitän vom FC Fulham, Bernd Leno. Nicht schlecht, mein Lieber. So Mario, über wen wollen wir in der Serie A noch sprechen?
Ja, zum ersten muss ich natürlich sagen, wenn Yogi London kommt drauf an, wie viele Tage dann und wer das Abendessen zahlt, aber sonst würde ich das natürlich…
Das würde ich bezahlen. Mario, du trinkst mittlerweile nichts mehr, das wird billig, das passt.
Stimmt. Aus Italien würde ich gerne einmal, weil wir haben in der Vorbesprechung ja auch kurz gesagt, hatten wir noch gar nicht und deswegen ist so ein bisschen mein bislang zu wenig besungener Held Raffaele Palladino, der Trainer der Fiorentina, ein bisschen stockend reingekommen in diese Saison. Gab ja ein Trainer-Karussell, der war letztes Jahr in Monza, er hat jetzt für Italiano bei der Fiorentina übernommen, der ja zu Bologna ist, weil Motta zu Juve ist, wer das alles nicht mitbekommen hat. Und dann ging es bei der Fiorentina los mit einer sehr durchwachsenen Europa Conference League Qualifikation gegen einen ungarischen Vertreter, wo man dann auch ins Elfmeterschießen musste. De Gea hat da gehalten, dann hat man in der Liga nur einen Punkt gegen die beiden Aufsteiger plus auch Monza, die es ganz unten drin stehen, geholt, nochmal gegen Atalanta verloren. Und jetzt sind die, wenn die heute nach der Aufzeichnung wird noch gekickt, gewinnen, sind die dritter. Und die letzten Spiele waren 6-0 bei Lecce, dann 4-2 in St. Gallen, dann haben sie die Roma 5-1 weggefiedelt. Mois Ken trifft auch einmal das Tor wieder. Und das liegt eben auch an einem, wie ich finde, sehr smarten Trainer, der sich auch nicht zu schade war, sein System ein bisschen anzupassen. Zu Beginn der Saison noch mit einer 3er-Kette gestartet. Das war so ein 3-4-2-1. Jetzt spielt er meistens wieder mit einer 4er-Kette hinten, wo er dann auch links uns Robin Gosens, der hoch und runter rennt, der, glaube ich, da auch wieder einfach in Italien sein Fußballland gefunden hat, wie ich sagen soll. Das ist Wahnsinn. Die Fiorentina ist auf jeden Fall eines der Teams, bei denen das Trainerkarussell stand jetzt, positive Spuren hinterlassen hat. Wir erinnern uns vielleicht auch noch bei der Viola, die zwei Conference League-Final ist, in denen sie eingezogen sind, wo sie dann kaum Torgefahr entwickelt haben. Das war irgendwie unter Italiano, der auch ein guter Trainer ist, keine Frage. Aber immer so ein bisschen das Problem. Und jetzt kommt Palladino und schmeißt die Offensivmaschine an. Ja, auch Gegentore finden tatsächlich auch statt. Aber aus neutraler Sicht kann man sich das durchaus angucken, was Florenz da so zeigt.
Aber wirklich, haben vielleicht auch der ein oder andere und die ein oder andere mitbekommen, dieses 5 zu 1 gegen die Roma. Da darf man zumindest mal spielen. Und dann verursacht er ein Eigentor und kriegt mit 1 zu 5 auf die Mütze. Aber so geht es eben. Und wir wollen bei den Trainern bleiben, Nils. Du hast uns auch einen Trainer mitgebracht, und zwar einen großen Namen.
Einen großen Namen, das ist der von Manuel Pellegrini. Also der wurde schon durchaus oft besungen, auch in der Fußballwelt. Er hat ja schon einige Stationen hinter sich. Er wurde nur nicht unbedingt immer besungen nach Spielen gegen die Top 3. Also er hat eine sehr schlechte Bilanz eigentlich gegen Greer Madrid, gegen Barcelona, gegen Atletico und das auch mit Bettis. Da hat er aus insgesamt um die 40 Duellen erst einen Sieg geholt. Die Serie konnte er jetzt ein bisschen aufhübschen am Wochenende, da hat er nämlich Diego Simeone im 13. Anlauf zum überhaupt ersten Mal geschlagen. Und da steht so ein bisschen die Geschichte über diesem Spieltag. Der älteste Trainer der Liga, Pellegrini, mit 71 Jahren, hat den dienstältesten Trainer Simeone geschlagen. Und ja, zeigt ein bisschen, dass da jetzt Bettis irgendwie, der Held jetzt seit einigen Jahren weiter oben hat, der auch 2022 Pokal gewonnen. Jetzt sind sie wieder irgendwie auf Platz 6, gleich mit dem fünften aus Bilbao. Direktes Duell am Wochenende. Also das ist schon stark, was Pellegrini da Jahr für Jahr macht. Mit auch einem Club, der auch ziemlich viele finanzielle Probleme hat.
Aber wirklich über 200 Spiele jetzt schon für Bettis. Und wir haben Bettis immer mal wieder positiv erwähnt. Und dann viel sein Name auch. Aber das ist wirklich nochmal, wenn man sich diese Trainerstation anguckt. Ich meine Real Manchester City dazwischen. Aber auch immer wieder verschwunden, sage ich jetzt mal bei West Ham war er dann jetzt zuletzt. Es ist einfach ein faszinierender Trainer, der ja auch über 70 Jahre, 71 Jahre inzwischen schon alt ist. Unglaublich. Frisur gleichgeblieben. Alter. Aber nach oben gegangen. Sehr, sehr schön. Manuel Pellegrini. Haben wir den hier auch noch untergebracht? Und wen bringen wir aus der RE. Divisi noch unter, Daniel?
Wir bringen einen Bekannten aus von Werder unter Debbie Claßen. Der ist jetzt bei Ajax gesetzt. Und das ist auch schon das Besondere im Prinzip, schon teilweise, denn Fahri Yoli ist ein Meister der Rotation. Der fängt jetzt die Medien und auch auf Twitter. In Social Media gibt es hervorragende Memes, die sagen, der dreht völlig durch. Der wechselt teilweise fünf, sechs Mal in der Startelf durch, hat eigentlich nicht so einen wirklichen Kern. Und trotzdem bringt es langsam den Erfolg. Da hat sich jetzt auch, glaube ich, Zorrel Harto, der 18-jährige Linksverteidiger von Ajax, auch geäußert, dass die Mannschaft sich damit arrangiert hat und abgefunden hat mit diesen Wechseln. Aber es funktioniert und hat vor allem den Vorteil, dass es für die Gegner sehr unberechenbar ist, wer denn eigentlich dann mit welcher Elf Ajax spielt. Aber Debbie Claßen ist davon beides genannt ausgenommen. Gegen Karabach international in der EL war er jetzt nicht in der Startelf, aber in der Liga, glaube ich, jetzt vier, fünf Mal in Folge, hat auch schon vier Tore in sieben Eintrassen gesammelt als Mittelfeldspieler und übernimmt sofort Verantwortung und ist auch für diese relativ junge Truppe, die Ajax mittlerweile aus verschiedenen Sekunden jetzt zusammen hat, auch, glaube ich, als eine Art Mentor und Leader einfach sauvichtig geworden. Und jetzt bei dem Klassiker gestern gegen Feyenoord hat auch eben Jena Harto im Interview nochmal betont, wie wichtig auch ein Henderson ist und wie wichtig auch vor allem ein Klaassen ist für nicht nur diesen Sieg, sondern generell auch für diesen Aufschwung, den Ajax jetzt erlebt. Und Klaassen ist ja auch so, das Gesicht im Prinzip von Ajax war ja schon zweimal dort, ist da groß geworden, steht eigentlich für die ganzen, auch die guten, erfolgreichen Zeiten, die Ajax erlebt hat. Und ist trotzdem so ein bisschen ein Ansagengeber, weil der Fokus dann doch eher auf den Talenten liegt, wie eben Harto oder auf Rückkehrer, wie Neuankömmlinge wie Wechors zum Beispiel oder wie Kachotz, der junge Belgier vorne in der Offensive, der auch sehr viel jetzt im Fokus steht. Und so ein, ja sag mal, alter Hauding wie Klaassen ist dann nicht mehr so, kriegt nicht mehr so die Blumen, die er aktuell verdient, weil er momentan echt nochmal aufpült im Prinzip und für Ajax extrem wichtig ist aus verschiedensten Gründen mit den Toren, die Stabilität, die er reinbringt und das Leadership, was er hat. Und deswegen will ich ja unbedingt noch an der wie Klaassen hervorheben. Und wer es schafft, unter Fahrioli so eine Art Stammspieler zu sein, der hat es geschafft. Also insofern der wie Klaassen. Alle Augen auf ihn.
Sehr, sehr schön. Ja, Francesco Fahrioli. Ich glaube, über den werden wir noch häufiger sprechen in den nächsten Jahren. Kam ja von Nizza und das, was da aktuell mit Ajax passiert, das sieht sehr, sehr gut aus. Einmal springen wir noch durch die Ligen hindurch. Wir beginnen wieder bei der Premier League. Jogi, was ist so eine Geschichte der Woche, die man noch wissen muss?
Ja, das Spiel Arsenal gegen Liverpool. Ich glaube, das war nochmal sehr, sehr interessant, weil es ja doch ein sehr verrücktes Spiel war und da ja auch dann wieder eine Menge Ärger gab um die Geschichte– ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es mitbekommen habt– mit Kai Havertz, als der ja quasi den Ball annimmt, durch ist, mehr oder minder, und dann aber der Pfiff erfolgte und keiner eigentlich so wirklich wusste, warum es gepfiffen worden ist und dann aber ja auch nicht wirklich aufgelöst worden ist, dann aber in der Folge rauskam, dass er wahrscheinlich selbst wenn der Pfiff nicht gekommen wäre, also viel Konjunktiv, trotzdem wahrscheinlich dann den Pfiff gehört hätte, im Nachhinein durch den VAR, weil er mit dem Ball da oben mit der Hand gespielt hat, so am Oberarm und das dann dementsprechend genommen worden wäre und gab Ich hab ne Menge Diskussionen dann auch bei Schiedsrichterentscheidungen, zum Beispiel Van Dijk, der hat dreimal ausgetreten gegen Kai Havertz, zieht dafür nur gelb. Dann gibt's noch ne Geschichte von Martinelli, wird im Strafraum von Conaté umgehauen, gibt keinen Straffluss. Also Arsenal hadert gerade so mit den Schiedsrichtern. Es ist nicht so, dass sie irgendwie verpfiffen werden oder so, das gibt's ja sowieso nicht, aber es ist schon so, dass sie Entscheidungen momentan nicht für sich bekommen. Das muss man schon sagen, das war ja schon öfter zu sehen, dass dann im Endeffekt einfach auch bei den roten Karten, wenn es sind drei in der Zahl jetzt schon wieder in dieser Saison, da hätte man bei der einen oder anderen vielleicht auch ein Auge zudrücken können, aber sie kriegen die einfach. Und das ist einfach momentan etwas, die werden schon erwischt. Was vielleicht auch daher kommt, dass Mikkel Arthäter da draußen auch immer rumtollt, es gab letzte Saison, wissen wir aus einer sehr, sehr guten Quelle, dass Schiedsrichter angehalten worden sind, in der Premier League Hertha durchzugreifen, weil sie gesagt haben, sowas wie Mikkel Arthäter da draußen macht, geht nicht und das dürfen wir nicht einreißen lassen. Das zeigt ja schon, wo der herkommt, zeigt, wie der da draußen ist. Und ich glaube, dass Arsenal da momentan bei den Schiedsrichtern jetzt nicht gerade die größten Sympathiepunkte hat, was nicht heißt, dass ich jetzt sage, dass da irgendwas gegen sie läuft, nur sie kriegen halt wenig Bonus. Sagen wir es mal so.
Also am Ende war es dann eben ein 2 zu 2, ein Unentschieden, da mit Liverpool vier Punkte vor Arsenal. Und auch deswegen natürlich da sehr viel Ärger drum. Kurze Frage mit– bitte um kurze Antwort. Wenn ich mir bei dem Spiel angucke, 9 zu 9 Schüsse, war das jetzt dann trotzdem hochintensiv und hoch dramatisch oder haben die sich gegenseitig plattgecoacht?
Da war schon was drin. Also ich fand vor allem halt sehr, sehr giftig. Das hast du von Anfang an gemerkt, dass beide eine Vorgeschichte miteinander haben und das Beides sehr, sehr ernst genommen haben. Und auch da sind ja wirklich Streithähne drin ohne Ende. Also Kai Havertz, ich sage das auch immer wieder, wenn der in Deutschland immer als soft oder sowas verschrieben worden ist, schaut euch den mal an. Schaut euch den mal an, wie der ist teilweise drüber. Dass der einfach dann einen Verteidiger mal anschubst oder irgendwie drauf tritt oder auch mal eine Geste macht oder so. Der ist schon, das ist momentan genau das Gegenteil. Das ist eher so ein Aggressivling und Van Dijk dann auch noch und so. Also das war schon nicht ohne die beiden Trainer dann auch noch gegeneinander. Also das ist schon, da war eine Menge drin in dieser Partie und ich glaube, ich bin selten so oft angeschrieben worden dann, was sagst du zu dieser Szene, das muss doch sein, das ist doch das und das. Also das war auch, hast du gemerkt, dass auch die Zuschauer richtig angezündet waren. Ich weiß nie, woher das kommt, aber es war wirklich sehr, sehr schön zu sehen, was ein Spiel dann machen kann mit deiner Timeline.
Ja, und was ein Spieler manchmal auch mit einer Timeline machen kann, das haben wir bei der Geschichte, die Mario mitgebracht hat, bekommen. Wir haben viele Anknüpfungspunkte. Ich hätte jetzt jede Stiche rauspacken können von Joki und damit eine Überleitung bauen können zu Mario Balotelli.
Ja, ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie sehr sich da die Schiedsrichter in der Serie A drauf freuen. Ich kann nur sagen, bislang ist es ja noch gar keine Geschichte. Die ganzen Geschichten kommen noch, aber ich freue mich mausmäßig drauf. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das großartig Sinn macht für den CFC Genua, aber es ist ein großes Spektakel.
Aber wie kam es denn jetzt dazu, dass er zu Genua gewechselt ist?
Na, er hat ja keinen Verein mehr seit Juni gehabt. Er war davor noch bei Adana Demispor. Wie gut er sich selber fit gehalten hat, wage ich nicht zu beurteilen. Genua war letztes Jahr so ein bisschen ja als Aufsteiger das Team der Stunde. Dann hatten sie aber gerade offensiv großen Adalast. Sie haben Albert Gutmundson abgegeben an die Chorentiner. Matteo Retegui haben wir, glaube ich, habt ihr vor zwei Wochen ja auch darüber gesprochen, der bei Atalanta alles zerschießt, geht denen auch ab. Sie haben sich Pina Monti, wie ich finde, auch einen Stürmer mit Zukunft geholt. Trotzdem sind sie jetzt Letzter und tun sich sehr schwer. Alberto Ciladino meint, dass es ein Upgrade ist, auf jeden Fall noch Mario Balotelli jetzt in der Mannschaft zu haben. Also ich finde das eh. Alberto Ciladino coacht Mario Balotelli. Er kann jetzt da ankommen und dem wirklich sofort weiterhelfen.
Könnte aber auch Max Kruse bei Paterborn werden.
Genau, ich weiß nicht. Der ist jetzt 34. Ich meine, dass der über eine große Qualität verfügt. Das ist unbestritten. Der kann die einen aus 40 Metern ins Netz schweißen und haut das Tornetz raus. Der hat auch noch seine Tore klar in der Türkei gemacht und bei Sion davor, Nitsa. Er ist halt ein streitbarer Charakter. Ich glaube, das da gibt es nicht. Das ist entweder so oder so. Entweder ganz weit, entweder großes Chaos oder es funktioniert, aber so, dass das jetzt einfach ruhig läuft und der da sagt, ja, gut, wenn du willst, dann komme ich die letzten zehn Minuten rein und versuche mal. Ich sehe es nicht kommen. Und auf der anderen Seite frage ich mich natürlich auch als Stürmer, da ist in dem Kader, dass du dir dann irgendwie Ende Oktober denkst, okay, und jetzt holt ihr den Balotelli oder was ist eigentlich euer Problem? Also, das birgt ganz viel Zündstoff und ich freue mich. Und so ist, glaube ich, auch das große Medienecho, dass sich sehr viele freuen, dass der verlorene Gang der Sohn wieder zurück in der Serie A ist, so ein bisschen, weil ich meine, der hat ja trotzdem schon auch einen Stellenwert und da auch jetzt das Standing ist nicht nur komplett Chaos-Kit. Wir erinnern uns, der hat auch für die Nationalmannschaft das ein oder andere gute Spiel gemacht. Also, ja. Aber ich glaube sozusagen, die wirklichen Geschichten, die kommen erst noch mit Ihnen jetzt.
Stark, das heißt, es ist quasi eine Geschichte in der Zukunft. Und dann springen wir von einem Tabellenletzten, nämlich in der Serie A, zum anderen Tabellenletzten. Ich habe es vorhin schon kurz angedeutet. Nils in La Liga, nämlich Valencia. Was zur Hölle ist denn schon wieder mit Valencia los?
Da gibt es mal wieder an sich genügend Stories, jetzt auch mal abgesehen von der Flutkatastrophe um Dana, was mehr auch um Valencia drum herum ist. Aber ja, Valencia mal wieder Tabellenletzter. Und dort ist jetzt, das ist erstmal natürlich eine krasse Geschichte, dass dort die Negativspirale weitergeht, nachdem sie sich in der V-Saison noch eher gehalten haben. Aber irgendwie ist da wieder absolute Krise angesagt mit einer sehr jungen Truppe, die auch natürlich gut ausgesaugt wurde. Darüber will ich eigentlich primär reden vom Investor Peter Lehm, der die letzten Jahre natürlich aufgefallen ist, eher die Spieler zu verkaufen als irgendwie zu investieren in den Vereinen oder geschweige denn in die Infrastruktur. Deswegen hat ja auch der FC Valencia oder die Stadt Valencia die WM 2030 noch nicht bekommen oder da ist noch kein Standort und versucht jetzt doch noch irgendwie am 9. Nesteia das irgendwie hinzubekommen. Aber die Geschichte ist da eher von Peter Lehm. Das war jetzt während der Länderspielpause, also schon wieder zwei Wochen her. Da gab es nämlich ein Ehepaar aus Valencia. Die haben ihre Flitterwochen in Singapur gemacht und dort lebt Peter Lehm und da haben die sich gedacht, so auch ja komm, wir fahren mal vor das Haus von Peter Lehm. Ich habe hier mein Lehm-Go-Home-Plakat dabei. Das sieht man überall in Spanien, auch bei der EM habe ich es oft gesehen. Also die Proteste gegen Peter Lehm, ohne dass das jetzt eine krasse Beleidigung ist. Damit hat der Typ sich dann vor dem Haus von Peter Lehm ein Foto ablichten lassen. Dann hat er wohl auch noch ein Sticker Lehm-Go-Home auf die Gartentür von diesem Haus gepappt. Und auf einmal heißt es, die beiden sind festgenommen, irgendwie in ihrem Hotelpässe abgenommen. Und das jetzt nicht von Behörden, offiziell Polizei, sondern dann irgendwie Sicherheitsdienst. Nach ein paar Tagen sind sie wieder auf freien Fuß gekommen, wenn man das so bezeichnen will. Und ja, war so eine kleine Machtdemonstration von einem Investor, der gezeigt hat, hey, mit mir solltet ihr euch nicht weiter anlegen. Also, ja, ein bisschen unschöne Szene. Wie gesagt, das Ehepaar ist längst wieder in Valencia. Aber da hat Peter Lim mal ein bisschen Muskeln spielen lassen, was ich jetzt gar nicht so cool meine, wie das vielleicht klingt.
Oh, der Typ, ey, der wäre ein eigenes Tribünengespräch wert. Aber ja, eine Episode von vielen von Peter Lim. Und ich hatte bei meiner Launing-Überleitung total vergessen, was in Valencia passiert ist. Also das sollte nicht so launig rübergehen, denn das sind ja ganz anzuresorgend, die man da gerade dort in der Region und ja nicht nur dort hat. Also sorry dafür. Da war ich kurz im sportlichen Gefangenen. Da gehen wir jetzt aber auch hin bzw. wir bleiben da, nämlich wenn wir nochmal auf die Ehre-Divise blicken. Welches Märchen hast du jetzt diesmal für uns dabei? Es begab sich zu einer Zeit, das Daniel vorgetragen hat.
Wenn wir in dem Sprachbild bleiben, ist es ein Märchen des Krauns. Jetzt ist ein neuer Rekord der Ehre-Divise aufgestellt worden mit fünf Eigentoren an einem Spieltag, jetzt am vergangenen Spieltag. Und das Märchen des Krauns geht weiter. Zwei davon diesen Spielen sind auch 1-0 geendet. Das heißt, wir hatten dann wirklich zwei, vermutlich sehr traurige Profi-Spieler, die das verantworten haben. Und das waren teilweise Eigentore, wo man sagen kann, gut, da kannst du nichts für, das ist blöd abgefälscht. Oder wenn du nicht hingehst, da kommt der einlaufende Stürmer, der anders. Du hast aber auch zwei Dinge dabei, die auch für dich herausragend in ihrer Negativität sind. Du hast einen Rückpass auf den Torwart, der Torwart steht halt nicht mehr im Tor. Sondern man wollte sich anspielbar, wollte sich eine Anspielstation anbieten, irgendwie links oder rechts vom Tor. Und der hat ein Hadega, guckt nicht wirklich hin, sieht ihn, er wird angelaufen, passt zurück zum Torwart, da gut, er ist halt nicht mehr im Tor. Und das andere eigentlich, was auch herausragend ist in der Schönheit der Zerstörung, wenn man das mal so formulieren möchte, ist eine Klärungsaktion von Bakuna von Groningen, in der auch leider schon 84. kurz vorm Ende, die hat noch 0-0. Wenn er im Getümmel will, er den Ball klären, möchte ihn seitlich wegschaufeln, trifft ihn aber voll spannend in der Mitte und knallt ihn unter die Latte des Eigentorwagens. Die kann man sich auch noch anschauen auf Instagram und Twitter bei ESPN NL, müsste noch ein bisschen abrufbar sein. Kann man sich mal anschauen, ist sehr, sehr unterhaltsam, auch wenn es ein bisschen traurig ist. Ich habe mir dann mal überlegt, wo ist der Report in der Bundesliga? Der steht auch bei fünf Gegentoren. Und der ist aus der Saison 15, 16, 13. Spiele 15, 16, unter anderem. Und so können wir den Kreis, glaube ich, schön schließen. Mats Hummels hat da einen Eigentor natürlich produziert für Dortmund und der Nutzer, dieser war der HSV, lang ist es her. Und die haben 3-1 gewonnen, HSV gegen Dortmund, unter anderem Mats Hummels. Also, das ist der Kreis. Die Eredivisie zieht gleich mit den meisten Eigentoren an einem Tag mit der Bundesliga.
Und damit sind wir am Ende da gelandet, wo wir alle hingehören, in Deutschland, in der Bundesliga. Aber Mats Hummels, wie er hier erwähnt wurde, das wird ihm nicht gefallen. Aber gut, kommt für ein Tribüngespräch vorbei, dann können wir auch über andere Themen sprechen. Ihr vier, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt an diesem Donnerstagvormittag. Mario, Rika, Nilskern, Jogi Hebel, Daniel Zander, herzlichen Dank, dass ihr mit dabei wart. Danke euch. Wir müssen irgendwie das mit der Verabschiedung, ich krieg's nicht besser hin, da muss ich mir mal noch mal was überlegen. Was ich aber auf jeden Fall hinkriege, ist, euch zu sagen, dass der Rasenfunk weiter werbe, paywall und sponsorenfrei bleibt. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Sam Chris, bei Frank Rossdeuter, bei Merckx, beim Würzburger, beim Grasnarben-Sammler und bei Björn. rasenfunk.de/supportersclubdaerfahrtihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und ihr könnt uns auch unterstützen, indem ihr diesen Rasenfunk hier bewertet, diesen Podcast hier bewertet und uns weiter empfehlt. In diesem Sinne bleibt gesund, bleibt uns gewogen und bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Macht es gut. Ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.